Kellyanne Conway decided to coin a new
phrase to participate in the lies about
the terrible pathetic embarrassingly low
attendance at Donald Trump's
inauguration the term is alternative
facts yes we know Kelly you've had them
the entire campaign another name for
them as lies here is her coining the
term excuse and you did not answer the
question you did not answer the question
of why the president asked the White
House press secretary to come out in
front of the podium for the first time
and utter a falsehood why did he do that
it undermines the credibility of the
entire White House press office so don't
be so overly dramatic about it chocolate
what it you're saying it's a falsehood
and they're giving Sean Spicer our press
secretary gave alternative facts
alternative facts four of the five facts
he uttered Zeke Miller for the five
facts he uttered were just not true
look alternative facts are not facts
they're falsehoods Chuck do you think
it's a fact or not that millions of
people have lost their their players or
health insurance and their doctor look
over here at this other shiny thing is
this the new fake news alternative facts
this is straight-up Orwellian I mean Pat
this is out of George Orwell's 1984
doublespeak yeah it's one thing when
you're having an argument with someone
and you bring your set of facts the
table and they bring their set of facts
but you have to agree on what the facts
are there's no what did she say there's
no alternative exist
here's the thing though that no one is
talking about in the first moment of
this interview she already doesn't like
the line of questioning and she
threatens to cut off access to NBC I'm
gonna play for you now what I just
played is getting a lot of attention and
rightly so alternative facts are called
lies or falsehoods in reality here is
her threat to NBC News why did the
president send out his press secretary
who's not just the spokesperson for
Donald Trump he could be this also
serves as the spokesperson for
all of America at times he speaks for
all of the country at times why put him
out there the for the very first time in
front of that podium to utter a provable
falsehood it's a small thing but the
first time he confronts the public it's
a falsehood Chuck I mean if we're gonna
keep referring to our press secretary in
those types of terms I think that we're
going to have to rethink our
relationship here we are going to have
to rethink our relationship if you
criticize the undeniable lies that our
press secretary utters as if he can't
even control himself this should be red
alert this is the authoritarian
fascistic stuff I actually think all
media should stop interviewing Kellyanne
Conway that will damage an anger Trump
and Conway way more than what's going on
and don't even allow her to issue these
threats you said Kellyanne you're off
we're not interviewing you because you
just lie and this is part of the broader
approach Pat that the Trump team has
which is create doubt about what is even
knowable and then when there's a
discrepancy you put the trumpet in the
position of deciding do I believe media
or do I believe Donald and a lot of them
we're going to choose Donald it's in a
way a brilliant strategy right the Trump
administration and their spokespeople
really just don't understand the dynamic
between government and the media right
the media is there to hold you
accountable and if you can't defend
yourself I mean try to come up something
else but don't revoke their access no
and this is this is exactly the type of
thing that we've been talking about in
the lead-up to the inauguration and it
is happening this is we're in the first
72 hours folks and we already have
straight-up lies provable lies
demonstrable lies from Trump Spicer and
Kellyanne Conway and included in that a
threat to revoke access to NBC News if
they don't do what Kellyanne wants
it's the Trump regime folks I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman talked to me about
it